for fish merchant ricky it's a 4 30 a.m
start every day
the fish he sells here in plymouth ends
up in restaurants across the country but
rising costs means cutting a deal with
fishermen and suppliers is getting
harder from the very beginning obviously
the boats have to
uh go out and catch it uh their fuel's
gone up
like i say double almost double uh so
therefore that's got passed on to us oh
um bill's in here i've gone through the
roof we've got to pass on to our
customers we can't we can't absorb it
as you can tell everything's gone up
it's just ridiculous
for ricky bigger bills are leading to
some awkward conversations
the restaurants and hotels obviously
they're going to look for the best value
they can get at all times that's always
been the case
but now it's even more important
restaurants can't afford to staff can't
afford to run can't afford to open that
puts us out of business which there
on the on on the reverse hand puts
fishers out that's when our business
what you realize is that everything is
linked catching these fish in plymouth
now costs more and it's not just us as
consumers who are having to pay
it impacts every business in the chain
we buy trays of eggs from a particular
local supplier they they used to be
three pound for a tray they've never
gone up to six pound so i'm having to go
somewhere else to source them
at cafe bene kerry serves up breakfast
but he's yet to pay herself for wage
with ingredients costing more and
cooking oil up 30
it's only a matter of time before prices
go on
our breakfast all day breakfast is seven
pound they haven't gone up since we
opened the business so that is something
that we need to be looking at it's trial
and error i'm a bit scared actually to
be honest to to pass that cost on so at
the moment i'm sort of
keeping it where it is
why are you scared
because i don't want people to not come
in i've worked really hard nearly two
years to build this place and i'm
i'm afraid by putting the price up too
much people just will go elsewhere
businesses in plymouth are only just
starting to recover from the pandemic
and while the government has announced
more financial help cautious consumer
spending and rising costs
could make for some tough choices
several people say to me they've got
they're going from nine staff down to
seven just so they'd have to cover the
wages
so that's two jobs lost
more pressure on the economy
it's just more pressure on everybody
around
dan white heads sky news in plymouth